before the world changed this was
political campaigning in America turning
neighborhoods knocking on doors
canvassing for votes now most of the
work is being done on the phone
it's another obstacle to overcome if
you're running for office particularly
if you're a woman and a mother the
reality is people look at you
differently they're like I can't tell
you how many times I've been asked well
where are your kids
Julie Oliver is running for the US
Congress in Texas one of a growing
number of mothers who want to change the
face of US politics
I think moms are the ones who have
really delivered powerful movements in
our country and whether it's black lives
matter moms demand demand action for gun
gun safety legislation
MADD you know Mothers Against Drunk
Driving it's always been moms who have
been pushing these movements to save
people truly like save people's lives
from gun violence police violence from
drunk drivers and so I think we would
have a completely different set of
priorities if we had a whole lot more
moms in Congress Anderson and the
presidency the Texas Democrat is being
backed by a group called vote mama it's
a political action committee it offers
support and mentorship to Democrats up
and down the ballot it was set up by a
mother who ran for a congressional seat
in New York she was the first to win
Federal Election Commission approval for
campaign funds to be used to pay for
child care
it was game-changing we have actually
seen 38 federal candidates take
advantage of the ruling since my 2018
ruling including that it's been men it's
been women it's been Republicans it's
been Democrats we've seen over 60 state
candidates now use this it breaks down a
major financial obstacle at a time when
more working parents are thinking of
running for office and it starts to
normalize what it looks like to run as a
mom with small children more states are
considering changing their laws to bring
them into line with the federal ruling
currently less than 5 percent of
Congress are working mothers not even
close to reflecting America as a whole I
know the sacrifices
takes to work and raise a family what
mama wants to give more women in
politics a voice we will not be pushed
to the side but first it wants to give
them a chance Allen Fisher al-jazeera
Austin Texas